hi there steve kaufman here i'm
back home after my um
trip with my wife in spain and portugal
we had a lovely time the portuguese
people have to be the friendliest people
that i've ever come across
and it was just time and time again in
different places different situations
different towns and cities we just found
them the gentlest most friendly most
genuine
people that uh that we've traveled uh
with and met
now uh one thing i'm gonna talk about
today is
is uh you know how do you manage like i
speak 11 languages how do you keep them
in your head that's a question i often
get
and uh you know i'm confronted now
having come back to
to vancouver and i pick up my russian
and i haven't looked at russian for
a month
and i had put a lot of effort into
learning trying to focus on
cases and and trying to remember which
what the endings were masculine
feminine neuter and uh of course all of
that stuff is gone and they're sort of
specific trying to remember what the
endings were
however when i listened to it i have no
trouble understanding it
uh
so i do think that that
you know i'm kind of i don't know but i
think we remember the language we sort
of naturally get used to the language
a process that we're not conscious of
but the conscious the things that we
consciously try to remember that we put
great effort into trying to learn
as we do sometimes in preparation for
exams
that stuff goes very very quickly
but things that we learn naturally and
sort of ingrain into our
our habits we don't lose all of those
quite so quickly
and i'm gonna do a little experiment
here because i had some people uh
comment on mistakes that i made in
german and a
in a video that i did quite some time
ago and then i had one of our one of my
viewers here say that you know you've
made all these videos thousand videos
and you don't you haven't made any in
german well i have but i'll do another
one in german and the reason i'm going
to do it in german is because i haven't
done any german for a long long time
german has these ridiculous cases that i
can't remember
so i'm really operating from zero
attempt to even try to pay attention to
the cases and just to see what happens
and
what the history of my german was that
as long as i was trying to study
declension tables i could never quite
get it and then as i started speaking
and listening and reading and just
enjoying the language more i got better
but i still make lots of mistakes
is
um
festival
um
um
fish
um
um
beat us in